all right I think we can get started
even if we maybe have some strag coming
in so let welcome
to thank you rmos uh I GNA speak about
uh strongly strongly polinomial
algorithms for uh subclasses of LP
and um let me start with a slightly
provocative chart and that is uh how
hard is it actually to solve fractional
multic commodity flow
problems um so there are sort of three
different regimes low accuracy high
accuracy and soling it exactly and um it
seems to get harder the more uh accurate
you become but then once you become
exact suddenly become simpler which is
Maybe a bit confusing but what I'm
plotting here on the y axis is the
relative hardness and this relates to
solving General LP in the same accuracy
regime so what I mean by that is if you
want to solve multicommodity flow to low
accuracy then this is uh relatively easy
with first order methods um there are
many results on that if you want to go
to the high accuracy regime that would
mean your running time should depend on
your error
logarithmically then suddenly you can
show that General LP can in weekly
polinomial time be reduced to these
multi flow problems this was shown by
ITA in the 70s and just last year um by
by Ding King and Jang it was shown that
you can do that in essentially linear
time and the size doesn't blow up um
there's a slight caveat that was sort of
exploited by Yan fund brand and Jang in
the same year um where they showed that
you can do a little bit better if your
graph is
dense um but yeah but once you go to the
exact regime then it suddenly becomes
easy Val of the general IP because you
can solve multic commodity flow problems
in strongly polinomial time and this is
due to them being so-called
combinatorial LP where your constraint
Matrix is integral and it's a still a
big open question whether you can solve
General LP in strongly polinomial time
so essentially the Gap that you see here
in running time is exponential relative
to General
LP okay and my talk is roughly
here um I care about solving
multicommodity flow problems or my
general combinator LP in strongly
polinomial time and I want to do it as
fast as possible relative to the high
accuracy sour of us that are very hard
up here okay um now I haven't introduced
the problem itself but in this audience
I can quickly go over the definition of
Mast flow problems and multic commodity
flow problems um as I said I will speak
about more General combinatorial linear
programs but they will be quite useful
as running examples throughout my talk
okay so for the minimum cost flow
problems what do we have we have a
directed graph on this directed graphs
the edges have capacities and cost and
the vertices have certain demands and
our task is to Route exactly the demands
throughout this network subject to
obeying the capacity constraints and
minimizing the overall
cost um the minimum the multicommodity
flow problem is essentially the same
except that you now route multiple flows
for multiple demand vectors B so in our
case I have a second demand vector B bar
that you have to rout through the same
network um these instances would be
essentially separable if I wouldn't link
the two flows by the edges that they
share so they share yeah so they have to
together obey the capacity constraints
and it turns out that this problem is as
hard as general LP for weekly polinomial
running time okay so these are the uh
two running examp that I will use in the
talk um so what happens for these
different accuracy regimes that we saw
in the begin beginning the graph that I
showed in the beginning so if you look
at an error Epsilon so I want to find a
solution to an LP that is almost optimal
it is almost feasible then the low
accuracy regime would mean I have an
algorithm that does so in running time
that depends polom on one over Epsilon
um classical methods would be these here
that achieve that then since the 70s and
early 80s we have high accuracy methods
these are methods that only depend polom
on the logarithm of my error these are
ellip methods and Tri Point methods and
if you want to solve an LP exactly so
you don't allow any error then usually
unless you are in the bit complexity
model you would go to the Simplex method
which doesn't have any running time
guarantee and then their specialized
interior Appo methods and proximity
based solvers and um my talk will fall
into the category of specialized Inter
Point methods
today okay uh let's speak a little bit
about computational models to make clear
what I'm working with um what many
people work in is the standard bit
complexity model which would be weekly
polinomial time algorithms where you
have a running time that is polinomial
in the number of integers so the size
the dimension of your problem and the
bit en coding L of your problem if you
want to drop the bit complexity
dependency L then you end up a strong
strongly polinomial time algorithm
so you have only poly n Elementary
operations comparisons and basic
addition multiplication and so on um and
there's a yeah okay there's the
additional requirement that you want the
space of your algorithm to be bounded
this can actually be a problem for
example if you want to solve repeatedly
linear systems essentially you can only
do that to polylog Def naively without
your bit complexity blowing up um and
then there's another model where you
essentially completely get rid of the
bit complexity dependency and these
would be real rum or BSS models so there
we operate on real numbers we given an
oracle that can add subtract and so on
these numbers and uh in this regime we
want to have only polom many in
dimension many um iterations to solve
NLP okay um and uh my result will fall
into this category of the real Ram model
and is polom there let me mention that
you usually it is possible if you have
such an algorithm at least for LP to
make it um strongly
polinomial uh with the caveat of losing
a few polinomial factors in running time
so there the thing that for weekly
polinomial algorithms you could somewhat
always round the numbers that you have
to keep the bit complexity under control
you can't really do that in the real rum
model because your model would become
too powerful but instead of rounding you
can do something for LP that is express
your current solution as a combination
of vertices which is doable and yeah but
again this this will cost you some polom
factors in running time okay um now what
is the state of the art for linear
programs for weekly poly solvers versus
um strongly polom solvers so we can
solve LP very very efficiently in the
weekly polinomial regime so since the'
70s and 80s we have these high accuracy
servers which can be turned into exact
servers if you allow running time
that depends polinomial on the bit
complexity and in fact we can do it
now from K Le song Yan F made it
deterministic and then Jang s Weinstein
and Jang showed that depending on what
the true value of Omega is they can be
potentially faster um we can solve it
now in m to the Omega time L however if
you look for strongly Pol polom time
algorithms it is still a big open
question whether they exists but General
strongly time algorithm and as you
mentioned yesterday even for the special
class of Mark of decision processes we
we do not know yet okay what we do now
is for combinatorial LP meaning my
Matrix is integral and the entries are
not too large we can then solve in
strong polinomial time this was due to
tardos in
1986 and uh crucially here the the
dependency is only on the entries in The
conuent Matrix it doesn't matter what B
and C are there can be essentially
irational numbers if my model allows me
to add
subtract real numbers any real numbers
then you can do it in strongly
polinomial time um and another big class
where you can do it in strongly
polinomial time is if your constraint
Matrix a has at most two nonzero entries
in every column so this was a result by
by Daniel Cedric Neil myself and and lzi
from this year but uh yeah this is not
what I'm going to talk about today um
and this sort of unifies many special
subclasses I mean it was known for Minos
flow for example where you would of
course have a one and a minus one but
you could have arbitrary real numbers in
these columns and then feasibility for
example was known but not optimization
and dual feasibility was also known but
not optimization so yeah this is sort of
a unifying result there um
so what my yeah what my talk is going to
fall into is a faster stronger polom
algorithm in this regime so you have a
constrained Matrix that is integral and
the integers are not too large
okay um for that I go a little bit into
into condition
numbers um so one way of of defining
sort of complexity of LP is defining
this condition number c by a and that is
the subn norm or the maximum subn Norm
over all bases of this Matrix
here okay so essentially you you bring a
matrix in basis form you look at the
subn norm and based on that condition
number it is possible to solve LP yeah
independency logarithmic on that
condition number um and for example if
you look for a flow
Matrix then the bases correspond to
trees
uh so your Matrix a to the minus one a
has this identity block corresponding to
the tree edges and then the non tree
edges The Columns correspond to the
fundamental cycle so every edge here
corresponds to an edge here and there
exists a unique cycle with your tree and
what these columns here sort of indicate
is whether the tree edges do appear in
that cycle and if they do then in
positive or negative Direction okay um
and sort of this this concept
generalizes to to General LP that
intuitively this condition number can be
described as follows say you want to
augment flow or you want to change the
value of a variable by
one and um you want to do that with a
vector F that is supported on a subset
big F on the
variables um and then the condition
number sort of the smallest number such
that you can always do that with some
flow f bar that is also supported on the
same set routes exactly one unit along
that edge and the supremum norm of that
flow is at most Kappa okay so this
example here essentially shows that for
flows this Kappa has to be one this is
sort of equivalent to saying that um
flow matrices are totally unim modular
um but it turns out why multic commodity
flow so hard is that Kappa is
exponential and that can be seen by a
very simple example and that is let's
say we have the first commodity here and
I want to route one unit of flow from
here to here and I can do that say
around this cycle here this is necessary
for the first commodity to preserve the
demands but now what could happen is
that I violate the um the edge capacity
on this Arc and say on this Arc as well
so I have to fix it and a fix it by oops
sorry by using the second commodity and
Route One to flow in the other direction
so that the total difference in capacity
here is zero now when I do that in this
second red commodity then I have to
again fix the demands and if I do that
then what I end up with is a flow of two
over this Arc here and now this gadget I
can repeat again I have to fix this with
the first commodity and I keep going and
if I keep doing this then it turns out
if I just want to change one unit of
flow over this Arc here I'm going to be
forced to change an exponential amount
of flow on another on another Arc and um
yeah this is sort of at the at the core
of the hardness of multicommodity flow
um and um yes I will I will sort of show
how you can how we can solve these
problems um somewhat faster than than
than known before
okay um so what is the state ofth art
for certain graph based LP and for
General LP so for this stands for single
Source shortest PA for the single Source
shortest path problem there was a
breakthrough result last year um shared
best paper at Fox 22 uh that both single
soci dis path and mean c flow can be
solved
in nearly and almost linear time or till
of
M um however if you want to solve it
exactly meaning strongly polinomial time
then single source to this path is bman
Ford order MN since the ' 50s and mean
cost flow is a result by by Jim oen from
the 90s that you can solve it in MN so
you have this linear gap of factor n and
now very recently a few weeks ago Jeremy
feineman put a prein on archive where he
claims uh to solve single sour shortest
path in strongly Pol normal time in MN
into the 8 over9 which would mean the
First Progress in about 70 years on this
so if that turns out to be correct then
this be this would say that okay the gap
between single path high accuracy and
exact is smaller than
linear um but yeah let's say until a
month ago or so the gap between high
accy and exact for these craft problems
was was linear okay now what is
happening for General LP in the regime
where let's say we do not have many more
variables than
constraints um then we've seen already
these high accuracy results where you
can reduce the optimality get by a
factor of two in m to the Omega where
Omega is the fast matrix multiplication
exponent um and if you and the reason
why there was an L in the last time I
showed that result was that you have to
do that uh you have to decrease the Gap
by a factor of 2 to the L to be able to
round an optimal solution solution um it
turns out that if you want to do that in
the real model so we don't allow bit
complexity dependency then you can still
do it as sados in polinomial time in um
the dimensions and the logarithm of the
maximum subd determinant I've shown the
slide before the maximum sub determinant
is sort of an upper bound on this Kaa
condition number um and we uh showed
that um this polinomial Factor can by
blackbox use of these accuracy solvers
be turned into a running time that is m
to the Omega + 2 times the logarithm of
that condition number Kappa so in
general if you have a high accuracy
solver with running time T then you can
turn that into an exact server with
running time T time m^ 2 times logarithm
of condition
number um so we see that the gap for
General LP between Hy and exact servers
would be IC while it at least until
recently is linear or was linear for
graph based problems so the natural
question would be to ask is that quatic
Gap necessary if you have more
complicated linear programs or should it
also be a linear Gap and uh yeah I can
show that in fact you can you can reduce
that Gap to to a linear
Factor okay so you can solve an P
exactly in the real Ram model in m to
the Omega + 1 times logarithm of the
condition number many iterations
okay so um my algorithm itself is an
interior appointment method and um this
is sort of different to the previously
fastest algorithms where I mentioned
that previously you would need to in a
blackbox way invoke Inter Point methods
but it turns out that if you want to
speed up these algorithms you have to
open the blackbox and do something very
non-trivial uh with these Point methods
to to make them faster for exact servers
okay uh we have seen already talks about
interor Point methods uh I will just use
the standard log barrier uh so let me
quickly uh go over this we saw a talk by
fos and by S on this so what you have is
you want to um yeah you define a barrier
function which tries to push you away
from the boundary of your your a
feasible region and then then you
initialize with a point that is near the
analytic Center of that feasible region
and then you drop this parameter
mu um to zero and once you drop it to
zero then this this optimization problem
is the standard optimization problem the
standard LP and from you going to
Infinity you essentially forget about
the cost Factor so this is why you end
up for Mu roughly being Infinity at the
at the analytic Center and then you
follow the path approximately to to the
optimal
solution okay
um so this is all well known a
particular interor Point method would be
the predictor corrector path following
method uh let me mention that modern
methods that are the most efficient
usually do not follow this predictor
corrector regime but however if you want
to solve an LP exactly then you have to
perform at least in some sort a
predictor steps that reduce your Gap
more efficiently than these standard
pessimistic methods are doing where you
reduce the Gap by a factor of 1 / root n
in every
iteration okay so what is happening you
start somewhere near the central path
you do predict a step which is
essentially trying to look for the
gradient on your or for the tangent on
your path you follow the direction until
you are too far away then you correct
and go back and you keep doing this and
standard analysis show that you will
need order root M many durations to
reduce the Gap by factor of two okay um
let me now come to
the limitations of the short step method
which can be easily exemplified by a
very basic very simple LP here my
polytop is just the uh infinity ball in
two Dimensions my central path is going
to be the origin and I give you the
objective that is minus Theta for some
very small Theta and one in Direction uh
in the y coordinate okay now
um what what happens it is easy to see
that the optimal solution is going to be
the right bottom
corner um however if you follow the
central path what is happening if that
Theta is very small is that initially
you will roughly follow this line
here so you make a lot of progress in
the objective value but you do not make
progress in reducing the distance to the
optimal solution
okay
and this Theta here I can in the real
model choose as small as possible so why
is that not a problem in the bit
complexity model either in the bit
complexity model Theta is zero and if
Theta is zero then my cost Vector is
just the vector 01 so my optimal
solution is down here my path would be
just the straight line down here so I
can find this in one iteration in one
step and in the bit complexity model if
Theta is not zero then it's sort of
lower bounded by two the minus bit
complexity or so so my angle is at least
two to the minus bit complexity in fact
that tells me that I only need to reduce
the Gap by a factor of two to the minus
bit complexity which you can do with
proportional to L many durations and
therefore you can find Optimal solution
in um yeah L time poly and many
durations however if Theta is not uh is
not bounded by bit complexity then you
know any shorts step method Theta could
be super super tiny would you need to do
yeah every in short step method would
fail to find an optimal solution uh
efficiently okay um yes so this this is
sort of uh how to overcome these
limitations I will I will explain a bit
later um let me now give an overview of
what is out there for exact ipms that do
overcome this issue so there was the
first in shareport method by stases Inu
in 1996 and there there follow-up works
by uh George Lan mono and soia that
showed that you can design an T Point
method that solves LP exactly within
this many iterations and each of these
iterations can be computed in strongly
polinomial time and every iterations
requires order and many linear system
solves uh we sped that up in 202020 uh
in 2020 uh where we showed that m to the
2.5 many iterations suffice
and just last year we had a result that
uh is somewhat Universal for uh for path
following a point method and that says
uh okay here we have an a point method
that will only require at most m to the
1.5 many durations as any path following
method that you design okay so for
people that care about fast algorithms
with high accuracy this m the 1. five
Factor may be very
unimpressive um because I mean in the
end root M many should suffice right um
but then again if you want to go to the
exact regime you can design LPS where
any inport method would require
exponentially many iterations uh to to
the dimension uh so yeah for that regime
this uh this sort of shows
uh the limitations of aort method and
essentially tells you that if there is a
strongly polom time interior Point
method out there for a certain problem
then this one here is as
well
yeah um what does path following mean
does it mean short step or would your
method that you're presenting also count
as path following so path following I
would uh call any Intero method that
follows approximately the centr path of
some barrier
function okay so the there are these
potential reduction methods that don't
necessarily follow a path we cannot say
anything about these we cannot compare
to these but if you follow to some
exponential Factor even some barrier
induced Central path then this algorithm
is as good as your algorithm and you
assume that the barrier is s yes
yes
um so sort of to head L will explain
without explaining the Inter Point
method the underlying geometry of how
many iterations you're going going to
need I will quickly speak about the
so-called straight line complexity um
defined as follows
um um The crucial notion for that is the
so-called Max Central path and that is
the following um I just draw a
two-dimensional diagram the x-axis is
the optimality gap the Y AIS is the say
select variable or the variable XI and
now I'm asking you look at the Su set of
your polytope where my Gap is at most G
and subject to that um my curve is going
to be the point that maximizes the if
coordinate okay very simple um very
related to to what shadow Simplex does
does um and if you project your polytope
onto the two-dimensional uh Space spand
by the objective factor and by the
coordinate XI then this curve is exactly
the subset of the uh of the boundary of
the polygon that you will get okay and
now the straight line complexity is the
following notion um the blue curve here
is the same as we saw in the last slide
you just scale this curve by a factor of
two and now what you do is you look into
this tube between these two blue and uh
yeah light blue curves and you try to
find as few as possible linear segments
in that curve and it turns out that the
number of iterations of your inter
method is determined by the number of
linear segments number of green linear
segments that you that you get
here okay um let me yeah so there there
are very basic properties of that curve
if you want to show that thre line
complexity is small you need to do a lot
more advanced things but one thing is
clear for example uh is that the number
of pieces that you would require is at
most the number of pieces that your
maximal path has so the number of uh
line segments of your Shadow and it
turns out for example for the maximum
flow problem the number of these
segments is only two so this would this
immediately gives you that Intero
methods are strongly polinomial maximum
flow okay um what we show in our paper
this year is that in
fact if you saw the result that you can
we can solve uh LPS and strongly
polinomial time whenever my Matrix
contains at most two non zero ERS per
column and it turns out that the
straight line complexity of these
variables is going to be strongly
polinomial and this is why we this is
how we show that that you can solve LP
with at most two n zeros per column in
strongly polinomial time additionally we
show that in fact the straight line
complexity is bounded by a linear term
so M times the logarithm of a condition
number okay so this result here the
first one that is about uh yeah I guess
20 Pages or so but the second one is
just it's just one page the proof of
this fits on one page now so now the
question is let us be optimistic and
take this rading complexity bound and
plug it into this result here um and
let's see what we get in the running
time so if you optimistically say that
amortized you can Implement every
iteration in m to the Omega minus 12
this is exactly the amzed running time
that you get for high accuracy solvers
per duration then the overall running
time would be the number of
durations times the cost per duration
and what you would get is m to the Omega
+ 2 * log Kappa so this is this would
match the result that we had 3 years ago
but uh I did promise you that we get
that we get this down to m to the Omega
plus one so new ideas and new insights
will be required to to drop the running
time by this linear Factor
okay good um again before I go into the
ideas of how to make method exact let me
show another pathological example you've
seen one before where we had the L
Infinity ball and where the angle of the
objective was very close to hyper plane
um but here is another example that is a
flow example and there will will we will
see how we can overcome these issues
that yeah if an angle is very close to
to to zero so it's the most simple
instance of a shortest path problem that
you can imagine I give you two vertices
a root R I use R here because I want to
use S for the selx
um and a Target T and I give you two
parallel
arcs and they have slightly different
cost so the first Arc has cost one the
second Arc has cost 1 plus Theta and
this Theta is is super super tiny much
smaller than one okay now it is easy to
see that the optimal solution to this
would be just send the flow over the
first Arc because it's
cheaper however what is the interior
Port method trying to do if you have a
large parameter mu
then the optimum is given by the
minimizer of the feasible flows of this
function here
and because Theta is so small the cost
doesn't really matter whether I sent it
over the first Arc or over the second
Arc however for this logarithmic term I
would really like to balance out the
flows of these two arcs so the problem
is now that it's going to happen that if
I'm on my central path or near my
central path I GNA send one half unit of
flow over the first Arc or approximately
one half unit and I'm going to send one
half over the second
Arc and this will not change I mean I
can arbitrarily arbitrary multiple
effect multi multiple factor of uh uh of
mu I can reduce my Gap I will not see a
changing behavior of that uh so what I
need to do is I need to go through the
Dual side so what the Dual of this
problem I want to minimize the sum of
the slacks subject to these constraints
so these are sort of the so the s is are
the reduced cost uh it is easy to see
that the optimal dual solution is given
by um of course the first slack being
being zero because we want to Route flow
in the optimal solution over the first
Arc and the cost or the slack in the
optimal Solution on the Dual on the
second Arc is going to be
Theta um but now my path on the Primal
side on the Flow side looks like this um
the x-axis is the gap the y- AIS is the
flow that are sent over the arcs so if
we have very high Gap if we start
somewhere close to the antic Center then
both flows are going to be roughly one
half and I would need to reduce the Gap
by a
lot to come to finally get to the Gap
Theta where fin finally the the the in
part method would learn which AR is
actually going to appear in the optimal
solution so here we will see that at
some point when my once my Gap is Theta
the first flow will go to one and the
second flow will go to zero so the
question is how can I accelerate my
interal Point method to go to this point
Theta efficiently okay um and if I look
on the Dual side what is happening
here is the following sort of you have
the complimentary Behavior because flow
times slack is always going to be
constant you have that uh all the slacks
are essentially scaling down to zero
until you hit again the Gap Theta so it
is easy to see again that okay for the
first slack you really just go down to
zero and the second slack is a slight
shift of the first slack so in
particular until I'm here at Theta it
really scales down as well so what I
suggest as an update you do that
manually you don't do that by uh
Computing the standard update steps in
your point method you would not touch
the flow on the on the Primal side
because that's the right thing to do and
on the Dual side you would set them by
hand to minus the first
leg and it will turn out that this is in
a good direction and you can will be
able to reduce the Gap until you are
here down at Theta and you can from any
point on the central path in a single
iteration reduce your Gap to the Theta
here okay so what you have achieved once
you've done that is that the second
slack is roughly where it's supposed to
be in the optimal solution the second
slack is roughly Theta um on the Primal
side still nothing has
happened but now you can use the slow
step once you at this point the slow
step to make more progress on the
central path because now now slowly the
first flow will reveal itself it will go
down will go up and the second flow will
go down to zero and then you do a second
update step by hand that really pushes
this flow to exactly one this flow
exactly to zero and this FL exactly to
zero so this is sort of need to do two
steps by hand to be able to turn the
standard RPM analysis into an exact
solver
okay um this is a very simple example
again the most simple example that you
can imagine um and it turns out that
roughly this strategy works for for
General
LP um in the following
way the predictor step that is sort of
the gradient on the central path is
given by the following system here so
you want an update step St Delta X that
is primar feasible which means it lies
in the kernel of your Matrix you want a
dual update Delta s which lies in the
image of a transposed uh and you want in
the third step here these are the
equations which tell which tell you that
you want to reduce the optimality
Gap and then you choose some step size
Alpha and go in these update directions
to reduce the Gap um now the question
question is how large can you choose
Alpha so that you don't go too far away
from the path and standard results are
that you can pick Alpha proportional to
1 / root M and therefore your Gap
reduces by by this
Factor however you can do much better in
an optimistic scenario and that is you
can reduce Alpha such that your residual
Gap is going to be something that is
proportional to the harar product of
your Primal update in local Norm x times
dual update in local Norm s okay this is
sort of a two- line proof that this
works out and this is something that we
exploited in this toy example on the
last slide where we essentially said
that Delta X Delta on the flow was zero
so in particular can reduce uh reduce
the Gap by a lot
okay um so far so good is
that
uh it doesn't really matter I think it
should be L2 because I mean
it yeah it should be L2 uh the gap
between the two Norms of course is at
most root n and if you can reduce the
Gap in two Norm then you just do slow
steps
afterwards you're concern with the chice
of because you to also get the
fast okay um I think there it it
wouldn't matter in the end but uh the
the um okay if you want to stay in L2
neighborhood of your path then it's L2
Norm so I guess yeah but I using the
algorithm is
L2 okay
um right so we have this linear
system we have this linear system here
that we're trying to solve and it turns
out that there's a very nice
interpretation in terms of you could say
electrical flow or for General LP it's
just an L2 regression problem and that
is if you're roughly centered then this
Delta X update is just the update in
Delta X Norm such that the residual Norm
X Plus Delta X is minimized subject to
the local Norm X okay um and why is that
intuition important it's important for
the following way for the following
reason let's say we have this LP here
where uh my central path okay we have
the cost function here that is uh going
upwards
my analytic Center is somewhere here my
optimal solution is down here and let's
say I am somewhere here on the path then
what is happening is that the slacks on
the blue arcs is on the blue um edges is
super small uh while the slack and keeps
getting smaller and the slack on the red
edges is slightly increasing but it's
essentially constant up to constant
factors okay and if you want to
accelerate on the central path then you
shouldn't solve the standard L2
regression problem but you should do it
in a more principled way namely what you
do is you you look at the layers namely
you order your variables by their value
and now you you see a gap in the in the
slacks between the third variable here
and the fourth variable Here and Now
what you do in the f is the following
this is what vasus and did in 1996 first
you sort of solve this al2 regression
problem by only caring about the
variables with small uh x
value here you would be able to set this
to zero namely the optimal update
direction would be exactly this point
here and then you fix the update in L2
this is what these equations are and
what you do now is you solve it on the
first set of variables again subject to
fixing what happens on the second side
and this will bring you in this instance
here to the optimal solution in a single
step
okay um it doesn't always bring you to
the optimal solution but this procedure
will always make you combinatory
progress in a certain sense um so let's
us generalize this whole concept to more
layers we just saw two but what you can
do is whenever you see a gap between
consecutive variables just create a new
layer and now you have this Primal SOC
called layers Le squared step that do
the following you first solve okay you
go down from the last layer to the first
layer you first solve the L2 regression
problem on these variables fix them then
you solve it on this fix them and keep
going and you do the opposite thing on
the Dual side recall that we have that x
times s is roughly mu so the order is
exactly revers on the Dual side L1 has
now the smallest stack variables and now
what you do here is solve the L2
regression problem here on the Dual side
fix the variables do it here and keep
going this is what you do and this is
what your update step is going to be
Delta X Delta s
okay and um in the analysis they show
that in fact you get at most n to the
3.5 log cap many um iterations and the
idea behind this is the following um you
need to make some sort of combinatorial
progress that tells you that
this step this LLS step doesn't need to
be done too often and in important
property that they exploit is that the
central path is essentially
monotone okay up to a factor of M so
that's by that I mean that if you look
at the optimal solution xstar then each
entry is at most nend times as big as
the entry that uh you've seen at any
point on the central path before and the
same thing on the Dual side and depicted
this can roughly be uh interpreted as
follows
recall the max Central path that is
maximize the if coordinate subject to
have a certain Gap now if I scale this
graph not by two as I did the last time
but by
m then it turns out that the central
path is going to be always in this
tube okay so it's not going to be
monotone it can do some some funky stuff
it can go little bit up then down little
bit up but it's essentially always
decreasing okay um and this is crucial
because of the
following and show that after a single
step you arrive at some parameter Gap
parameter mu bar so that there exists
some layer in your layering and
variables i j in that layering such that
the I
coordinate has essentially converged
meaning that the optimal solution is at
most a poly M Factor away from your
current value and again this means that
I'm essentially converged because I'm
monotonically decreasing essentially
monotonically decreasing and there's
also a dual variable J where the optimal
solution
is uh yeah only a poly Factor away from
a current
value and because of the fact that the
product x * s is monily decreasing with
mu you will have it that if you only
decrease mu
by this Factor here
which is only exponential which means in
log World which inod methods live in you
can do that in poly time you have that
the value of XI is going to be much
bigger than the value of XJ because
again SJ is converged so XJ has to go
down in particular if I is so much
bigger than J then they will never
appear on the same layer again because
recall we chose our layers subject to
their values roughly being the
same okay and this is combinatorial
progress you learn that I andj will
never appear in the same layer again
such pairwise uh information you can
learn at most cly many times and this
will give you uh the running time that
is poly M times logorithm of condition
number
okay so this was all Bas in in
1996 um but it turns out that you don't
have to make your layers separated by
such a big gap as they do so what they
did again is you build a layer whenever
you see a gap of uh again here switch to
Delta which is Maxum subd determinant
but it doesn't really matter uh whenever
you see a gap of that is that big then
you create a new layer turns out you
don't have to do that it is enough if
layers that are by index two a part are
separated by a polinomial factor in
Delta okay and that allows you to to
create layers essentially whenever you
don't need to be lucky or you don't need
to wait until a big gap appears so here
I only want the red part to be separated
by a gap to the gray part and the blue
uh part to be separated by the light
green part uh Again by by polom Factor
so it's it's a much finer layering that
you will build and you also have to
build a new update step um that I will
go over very quickly so instead of so
what we've done before Ras was the set
these here or we essentially solve the
L2 regression problem on these
coordinates while not caring at all
about what is what they are doing here
but now the problem is I don't have that
the gray part and the blue part are
separated by a big gap anymore in
particular if I just solve the L2
regression problem here while ignoring
what's happening on the blue part then
uh I run to problems because the gray
part influences the blue part by far too
much because they don't have separation
so I need to be careful in my update and
the care that you take is that you don't
ignore what is happening on L1 and L2
but you make sure that your initial
update is in a space that is safe for
you and that is uh the space is I have
defined here let me let me not go into
details um and in the Second Step you
look at the orthogonal space to the
space in the first space and you perform
the update here okay very high level um
bit too much Algebra I think so let me
let me skip over it um and also what you
need is a stronger convergence result so
here this is what we saw in Ras and Y
that there exists some layer for which I
and J exist where I converge in the
Primal side and dual and J conversion on
the Dual side it turns out that you have
a much stronger convergence result as
well and that is the following um
perform one step of this final LLY
square step where we don't look for
separation um and then
there exists a variable I and ball
around this variable meaning that I look
at all variables J that are only a PO
factor and Kappa away from from from XI
and then there exists a variable J in
that ball with the same properties as
for V
had okay so uh that essentially tells
you that you learn com information
quicker and also uh what you can show is
or what is easy to see it is that there
are also common tutorial events
happening for all other variables K that
are in your layer b or in your ball B
Because essentially either the X
variable in the XK variable will either
follow XI meaning it also converges or
it will follow SJ which means it goes
down on the Primal side so XK would go
down but then it will never be layered
together with variable I so
intuitively if you have a layer of size
L then you learn L
many
pairs very quickly so that is sort of
the uh the the summary of that and it
will turn out that um you can also have
longer step sizes so recall that in
general for General LP it is a big
question whether you are able to show
that you need less than root M many
iterations to decrease the Gap by factor
of two
but it turns out that the step size that
you can take is proportional to the size
of the layer that you have okay so
intuitively why you can only take or
Yeah by your step size is bounded by
root m is the following in every
duration of an interior Point method you
project the all ones Vector onto some
Subspace and the step length is
proportional to the supremos norm of
that projection now the the all one's
Vector has Norm root M so the supremum
norm can be up to root M and this is why
you get your step size um but it turns
out that if you have layers with a
certain Gap then the step size that you
can take is inverse proportional to the
size of the
layers
So in theory yeah it tells you that you
can the larger the layers are the uh
less progress or the yeah the larger
layers are the less less progress you
can make but you learn more common
information so this is the tradeoff that
you can exploit um and the same holds if
you don't have separation this is what
you can show you can show we can also
make these steps that long even if
there's no Gap only if there's a gap
between layers that are index two
apart okay so combining sort of these
two insides meaning uh I
find combinatorial events between two
variables quicker and I have larger step
lengths you sort of get this result okay
in root l or in root canaly man
iterations I can learn uh canl many
combinatorial events and what is sort of
left to show is that not only can I take
longer steps I can also compute these
steps faster in Mr test running time
than M2 the Omega minus
12 and um for this I will only give High
Lev ideas why you can do that um in the
following you perform some Matrix
multiplications uh sorry Matrix
operations that make that turn your
constraint Matrix into one that
corresponds to your layering in the
following way so let's look again at our
layering we have that the values of my
variables are separated whenever the
index is at least to apart and now you
essentially do some part IAL gusan
elimination where you want that it's an
upper triangular Matrix and the nice
property is now that if you get your
Matrix into this shape here then it's
almost a diagonal matrix because these
entries up here are not zero but they
are tiny and they are tiny because you
made sure that there's separation
between these variables here okay and
now what you do is with these rows is
okay uh it makes only sense makes only
sense if the row Norm is is one so they
are yeah these really don't matter uh
much and it turns out that uh if you
okay doesn't turn out but what you what
you have to do is you have to make these
blocks in rows orthogonal and I don't
mean you make the whole thing orthogonal
that would be too expensive but you only
make the parts where they meaningfully
intersect orthogonal because this here
Epsilon they are almost orthogonal on
this part and it only really matters
what's happening here and you make them
orthogonal you maintain their
orthogonality throughout your algorithm
and the important bit is that the IPM
performs projections onto this Matrix
here and if you have orthogonal rows or
block orthogonal rows then your projects
become much much cheaper just because
yeah I mean yes projection onto
orthogonal matri are trivial if they
block orthogonal the cost is
proportional to the size of the block
so that's Mak that makes the iterations
much much cheaper okay
um
right
so what I've done here is sort of for
the image of uh of the transpose of your
Matrix so what I maintain is sort of uh
matrices that are a decomposition of
your image space of your rescaled image
space that is orthogonal you can do the
same thing with matrices V on the Kernel
of your
Matrix um and now the analysis of the
algorithm that you will perform here is
a little bit different to standard
analysis of robust PM what normal robust
PM would do
is they sort of Define a potential of
your error of your of your centrality
error fi that is roughly supr Norm of
the arrow per coordinate and then you
show that you know even after long steps
you can bound that error after certain
uh yeah by a constant say however you
will not be able to do that here um
because we want to make larger step
sizes so we will not be able to bound
the total error but what we're able to
do and what is necessary and sufficient
is essentially whenever you have an
error here F this error can be
attributed to the Subspace so this error
decomposes onto the Primal and dual
orthogonal subspaces so in particular
what you can do is you Bound for every
of these subspaces the error that is the
projection onto that Subspace of the
gradient of your eror and you can show
that this is constant and with that uh
everything is fine you can show that you
have a faster robust IPM U again very
high level but uh this is uh how you can
design the improved running time so let
me summarize um we had so following tus
framework in 86 we found a
combinatorial algorithm that runs into
the Omega plus 2 um it turns out that
vasus and Y and followup work showed
that with an IPM you can achieve again
poly running time however not very
efficient and uh the new result is that
you can actually get this down to the
best known running time for exact LP uh
um for combinatorial linear programs um
and the tools are that you need compared
to and larger step sizes you need better
layering uh you need stronger
convergence results and then you need
the classical tools that is even lazier
updates and then all you know uh diamic
Matrix inverse this here is all sort of
um almost plugged in from uh CLS
2019 um
and yeah these things all combined and
carefully mixed you you get the overall
running time um still open is the
following what do you do about Spar
matrices so you you've seen on this last
slide that I had to manually made my
Subspace orthogonal so I cannot exploit
any sparity because I have to have
expensive Matrix operations to make to
make and maintain orthogonality so that
that is
unclear then what can you do for for Vi
matrices all of these arguments sort of
rely on some self Duality which you will
get by the standard lock barrier and
it's not clear how you would be able for
example to plug in the Le sital barrier
to turn essentially maybe a root oh
sorry this should be an M here to turn a
root M into a root n and um then of
course what is what should be the true
Gap be between um between strongly
polinomial algorithms and high accuracy
algorithms because even for I mean now
we see that maybe for single socialist
path the Gap shouldn't be linear but
sublinear is that same thing true for
General combinatorial IP who knows there
are certain barriers to that but yeah
okay yeah thank you and uh yeah that's
[Applause]
it
question aome questions to get us
started um
so can you just remind us what like what
is combinatorial LP here like what's
yeah um essentially all matricies that
are integral and don't have entries that
are larger than
exponential okay and then this Delta is
that the condition number that you it
would be the largest subd determinant so
all the results would hold for the modal
condition number that is Kappa um but
it's good intuition to think of the
largest determinant of your constraint
Matrix okay but I can have like I can
have like unbounded no I cannot have
unbounded entries here you you so if you
if you want to okay that's sort of the
the reason why it's it's better to think
of Kappa because for Kappa you could
even irrational you could have random
data where you not necessarily would
think of bit complexity bounds um it's
really about this condition number Kappa
yeah so the norm of a b to the minus one
a the maximum of
that
okay and then now just channeling Santos
and Richard a little bit because they
they have a paper on on doing like bit
complexity analysis for CLS yeah which
CLS does not do do you need to do
something like this or yeah on purpose I
wanted to go through the real r model
where I don't have to bother with that
um however if you you want to make this
work in the bit complexity model then
you lose a lot of running time and that
is because essentially I don't want to
have dependency on B and C I don't want
to like to have dependency on the bit
complexity of B and C and um what all
these algorithms by Santos M and Richard
would do is you know you need some sort
of rounding you need to access the bits
I don't want to do that I can do it
without it by just representing
Everything I Do by comlex combination of
vertices of my polytop
however that is expensive you need to do
some kadori type decompositions and it's
unclear how to speed this up yeah so I
don't have I'm not allowed to round
things and that's the
problem so for this nearly orthogonal
property does this kind of make this
latus reduction then by like when you
find something being
so small that you're looking for some
kind ofis that
this oh I'm not sure about relations to
lce reductions here okay um so what what
I skipped over sort of is
that either you are able to maintain
this author de composition or your
layering becomes invalid at some point
and if it's invalid then you also learn
combinator event so there's sort of an
additional layer of complexity that I
try to Omit during during my talk okay
so you're not really checking to see if
this is like n
hard oh no all I'm all I'm doing is um
is essentially G elimination and on top
of that I do some orthogonalization
that's
it a really quick question so uh is the
final algor is like deterministic at the
end yes okay
yes all right let's thank Bento
again and we have a break and we
continue as usual at